the other day Benji was standing outside
this broadcast then a window a broadcast
of some kind
he shows up in a horse's head really
Benji starts screaming it's me it's
Benji buh buh buh ok so then two guys
come out who are like security types ok
the two security guys are like get the
[ __ ] out of here you know more or less
Benji goes I'm a horse if you address me
as a horse and treat me like a horse
I will then respond to you
okay stop it these two guys they don't
look like they're kidding around Benjy
doesn't back down you could tell they
just want to hit him in the [ __ ] head
and they're standing in the middle of
the street they would have taken care of
this Oh have there not been an audience
years ago Benjy wouldn't just be dead
so Benjy screams him he wants me tree
like a horse some guy from out of
nowhere sees what's going on he figures
it out cuz these guys won't treat Benjy
like a horse right he just goes hey
horsey giddyup I'm Benjy goes like Ben
she looks at him and goes ok and then
Benjy starts Benjy still gets on all
fours in the dirty filthy New York City
Street he's walking around like a horse
he comes up to where the subway is he
throws himself down the steps that's
under someone the guys yeah I'm go horse
he went down like a horse the guy who's
yelling him go horsey perfect stranger
on the street cuz he figures out how to
get rid of bed this is not even accurate
II guys bendji then rolls down the steps
under the subway and comes out under a
truck the truck could have [ __ ] run
him over he's insane Benji what was that
about don't you care about living I mean
that's any of those cars that he's
neighing in the middle of the block look
all of traffic has stopped someone
should just run him over I think he
theses Andy Kaufman he's [ __ ] he
really is crazy you don't think he's
crazy watch that tape